are you are you in are you in the UFC
you watch the do you watch last Saturday
fight I do I did you which ones do you
want if I want though Anthony Pettis
fights - oh you did do you see before
that that one weekend was a great best
cards I've seen in a long in a very long
time but will you shot when I was
flipping between that and the Deontay
Wilder fight oh well you're really into
it then yeah wait did you was the owner
fight was that shocking to you I was
very much because I thought that the
Polish chick was gonna just destroy rose
no yeah and then when she got hit in
that first ten seconds and I saw her
reaction I was like that's not the
reaction of a girl that wants it better
than the other girl Rose hit her nice I
was like ooh and then Johanna instead
even like uh-huh it was like oh damn she
got shocked it was yeah a bit of a Ronda
really know what's weird is that you um
you wanna actually always gets hit in
the first round Valerie Letourneau did
that to her Claudia Delia did that to
her she always gets Jewish she's lost
the first round before so important but
it wasn't so much yeah you're gonna get
hit it's a it's a fight yeah but it's
how you react to the punch
yeah your face looked like oh you're
right you're okay
in a way that was harder or you know me
and she was like it started her like
holy [ __ ] this goes strong mm-hmm that
hurt you see Bisping is replacing uh
anderson silva yeah yeah it's so right
after this like how did GSP got a 40-day
suspension and and how did Bisping nine
fights in China you have to it's just a
medical suspension fork medical the cuts
and ride you know Bisping didn't look
good after the fight either he was all
beat up he was a lot a lot are you happy
about the GSP oh as a Canadian as a
friend of GSP yes you know you guys
crane well no I never trained together
I'm friends with his team more than him
right have you been it before yeah you
bet it before yeah yeah yeah
and then for our little brother that
didn't go so well on the undercard oh
yeah I was like is this a sign of what's
gonna happen in the main event oh I
didn't know you're a big [ __ ] MMA guy
we have an MMA minute on this pot yeah
so you think that you think that he's
ordell lives on my street yeah and while
I was training today he texts me but you
know if GSP fought Robert Whittaker he
would lose he would yeah I'm striking
he's not gonna fight at 185 70 be real
looking at how he had he's putting a lot
of muscle yeah get that belly he's
always got that weird belly and even
when he was a welter he would walk
around pretty heavy yeah I mean after I
think that for him they would probably
create a division between 175 177 I
think it is pretty silly though how it
goes from like when you go from
flyweight and it's 10 pounds over and
then once you get to like lightweight to
welter it's like 15 and then 15 that's a
lot there should be some catch weak Wow
that's what happened in boxing that's
how you know a super middleweight how
was 15 pounds of heart there's that hard
it's [ __ ] on yeah because there are
guys like for instance Brandon Vera is a
perfect example of a guy who couldn't
fight heavyweight because these guys
were 265 like Mark Hunt yeah and then he
at 204 he was just you know too big yeah
so he would always he was just not a
perv there was no place for him to exist
successfully or fight successfully yeah
even though he was you know there's
heavy weights that should be heavy
weights and then there's guys that just
can't make light heavyweight yeah but
you think that robert whittaker and GSP
that would be a great fight though I'd
be a great fight if GSP has another
fight before he fights Robert Whittaker
who who do you think would you like to
like ule where oh yeah he'll kill you oh
man
you think so I think you know so scary
yeah stop what he did Robert Whittaker
did yeah yeah and he didn't look that
impressive
he could be I think I think just people
walk through Jacare oh yeah I think so I
think so Jack arrays been looking
there's been some pardon expression guys
chinks in his armor
because Whittaker fights like like a
lightweight Dillashaw Whittaker does
angles he's a lot of movements yeah he's
different than those other two
traditional Moy time yeah what about TJ
versus Demetrius
that'd be great I was really unfair for
DJ for some reason yeah but he's got a
cotton yeah TJ's have to come down yeah
I know but like TJ versus DJ but it
would just be treated like a super
fighting up for a title like what are we
doing with us so he would go down to one
side oh he said I'm coming for your
title I'm coming for you
I think DJ is the best pound-for-pound I
think it easy how you drive away armbar
suplex arm that was ridiculous I do
helicopter arm bars in the gym and when
we're training we do we've done them a
few times and I'm like wow I feel so
cool doing it yeah but it's like it's so
risky mmm like to try it in you know
it's good when you're training your
rolling and and I you know I get you in
a little hop fun helicopter armbar but
yeah but that flying arm bone
competition I trained very real
you were wrestling should do it together
you know where do you train in terms of
Mikado's yeah yeah but would they make
fun of me when I walk in there you know
look at my body look at look at mine
look at my body I know but I your body's
fine you see have you seen huge people
there are you can go as I'm Eddie noogie
yeah yeah [ __ ] man you know John Jacques
is gonna go and train do a seminar 10th
planet in a couple of weeks really asked
me if I'd go with them mmm and I was
like I would get killed a 10th planet
yeah well I like key because it's slow
they're said there is something really
cool about learning with a guy even like
the chokes for you all the jokes my
fingers are getting nice and sore when
the graces do it make me sweat don't
like it
[Music]